à vos petites infos eurovision tiens
regardez qu'il ya on a nos poteaux
bicloo chérie tu as tu commences à
vallet cuir et je suis très content de
vous voir vous savez que les gens vous
aiment les chéris vous êtes confie t il
faut dire aux gens et à tous les jeunes
qui nous regarde mon chéri parce que
vous vous êtes vraiment des exemples
dire aux gens de rester chez eux pour
l'instant mon chéri vous savez quoi
une fois que tout ça sera passée bah on
fera un truc avec eux énorme voilà et on
habitera tout le monde on fera une fera
une fête de ouf voilà mes chéris ok je
me réserve individuel on avait dit allez
vas-y une petite blague vas-y vas-y
vas-y pas d'écran fleurs [ __ ] c'est
énorme et qui se tapaient sa mère vers
mais c'est pas mal t'inquiète pas il
faut tenter des trucs faut tenter des
trucs on est bien on est en direct le
shérif et vous savez que vous êtes et je
t'embrasse fort mon frérot à tanger roux
lui c'est mon délit non mais c'est vrai
mais oui tant confinement bon tu te fais
pas trop chier ah bah ouais là là et en
plus il adore jardiner mais je peux vous
dire ni d'une pelle et un à tour il te
fait des merveilles
es tu fais foot on déniche quelle forme
on chérit et comme on dit regarder
pourquoi pourquoi on a plein de stars
aussi qu'ils nous appellent parce que
c'est pour vous montrer
restez chez vous voyez voilà elie semoun
machepy les bo s'est passé pas bon c'est
pas braquer un garde et qui m'appelle
cboe der thiam baer bouder bouder bouder
en face time regardez comme il est beau
celui-ci savamment bouder mais tu as
bien fait elle encore en âge vous dit si
vous voulez lutter contre le coran
navires us le tajine sa maman chérie bas
on est là on bouge pas
avali telle blague a dit blake de bouder
base est moche ça c'est dans une boîte
et de loin et voit lui il voit une bosse
qui magnifique s'approche des 10 danses
à côté d'un buisson qu'elle a une odeur
répugnante et louis escudier madame
seward parfum est lui le parfait sa
peine et trois chats et bien vérifier
croit québec à bas prix dia qui
m'appellent par alan garros va
supplanter despite savamment stan mon
frère ou alors je suis très content de
t'avoir t'es où t'es top t1 parité on en
suisse et où tu bouges pas parce qu'en
suisse aussi vous est confiné dans la
même galère à ont besoin donc arrêté les
entraînements de tennis tout ça tu as
tout arrêter donc la saison elle va être
décalé parce que j'ai appris que roland
garros donc en mai c'était mort as-tu
d'après un témoin bravache le nifff
héros tu peux ranger ses raquettes et
bandeau qu'ils étaient des petits
poignets nantais finir bon il paraît que
s'arrête en septembre roland garros
juste après le us open c'est-à-dire nous
allons chez les us open et roland garros
sans président de la fédé nice
professionnels hébreu accuse la ja tu
veux tu veux que tu veux que je prenne
sans charge non mais je te jure stan
c'est quand même fou stan c'est un
immense champion san diego c'est un des
dix plus grands chocs l'on doit la folie
le dos tennis du monde voilà de
l'histoire de décès de ces vingt trente
dernières années il est peu quoique
roland garros et d'allemagne à deux
minutes j'ai eu à rafa nadal au
téléphone j'ai eu rogers l'âge et stan
tout le monde m'appelle syrie qu'est ce
qui se passe roland garros annulé oui je
vous le dit roland garros annulée si
vous voulez jouer wimbledon
eh ben vous irez dans le jardin d'elie
semoun voilà héros d'amour salut mon
gars doux ça va mon chéri savent après
roux tués
tu es en confinement c'est un mariage et
ses côtes arrivées hier pour le peloton
va s'en sortir il faut juste que les
gens les plus fragiles soit sauvé nos
familles nos parents les plus âgés et on
va s'en sortir on va s'en sortir et on
va sortir tous ensemble en tout cas je
devrais dire il a raison d'être parce
qu'il y est on est obligé on sera là
tous les soirs pour rigoler voilà frérot
et nous il ya des sushis car yves la cua
montferrand c'est bon on t'embrasse fort
longtemps et gaz qui a un amour de clics
est toujours là voilà arrivés en
confinement mon chéri non jure c'est
vrai mais c'est vrai tu as fait ton
frère mais frérot et je le dis à ceux
qui sont chez eux
on va avoir des têtes si ça dure 45
jours
préfères tu fait que manger hier j'ai
défoncé trois toiles tout choco bn
revers sur la tête de ma mère frère j'ai
des potes ouest où siège voilà on lit
donc on s'appelle voilà harry tu sais
que je t'aime mon frérot c'est ce qu'on
aurait dû faire
on aurait dû faire on aurait dû faire
les tests avant on est confiné avec
plein de gens et on fait que des dark a
faim et bat un amour mon mari que c'est
qu'on t'aime fort harris et un garde
mahmoud saméon l'aiment
sanaa un mec d'une générosité c'est un
kiff de may contain frérot et je te jure
que la moustache même la moustache tout
va bien j'aime comme ça tu es beau gosse
moi je ne suis pas revu depuis mais en
te kiffe mon mari est bons rails on
pense à toi